Speaker 1: An increasingly desperate,
panicked and unhinged failed, former
President Donald Trump released a cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs midnight video last night,
early this morning, wherein he calls all four
investigations into him just Democratic left
wing bias. In yet another sign that he
is both not only really scared but very,
very disconnected from reality. This video
was released through Rumble and embedded
on Troth essential. Here is Trump very late at
night, claiming that the weight of his massive
polling lead. Where did you think I was
going with that? The weight and size of
his massive polling lead is forcing desperate
Democrats to try to charge him, of course,
ignoring the reality that these investigations
have been going on for a long time before he was
even a candidate for 2024. Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: These four horrible
radical left Democrat investigations.
Speaker 1: By the way, I know people
seeing this are going to write to me and say,
David, how can you not comment on the fact that
it's not even orange that Trump is anymore?
It's almost like he he's he's painted himself
so dark that it doesn't even make any sense.
And his lips look white and fox. I get it. I
get it. But it's not the focus here. I get that
he looks like a like a reverse mind, I guess we
would say. But we're not focusing on that here.
Speaker 2: You're all time favorite president Me
is just a continuation of the
most disgusting witch hunt
in the history of our country. It's gone on
forever with Russia, Russia, Russia and Ukraine.
Ukraine, Ukraine hoax. It's an absolute disgrace
what's going on. They even spied on my campaign.
Speaker 1: Of course that's not true. Should I
explain that again? I guess I'll briefly just
be. It's been a while. I just I if you know the
explanation, I apologize. The the allegation from
Trump is that they spied on my campaign. What
happened was that Trump's 2016 campaign was
in touch with so many suspected criminals who
were themselves under surveillance that when
those suspects, suspected criminals would make
phone calls to people associated with Trump,
Trump's associates associates would
incidentally be surveilled because
they were talking to suspected criminals.
They weren't spying on Trump's campaign.
Speaker 2: And remember this with all of the
work that they did on Mueller, no collusion.
That's what the answer was, was all no collusion.
Whether it's the Mar a Lago raid or the UN Select
Committee hoax, the perfect Georgia phone call, it
was absolutely perfect. Or the stormy horse faced
Daniels extortion plot. There it is. They're all
sick and it's fake news. Our enemies are desperate
to stop us because they know that we are the only
ones who can stop them. And they know it very
strongly. And they are looking at the polls where
not me, but we are up by so much they can Wow it.
Speaker 1: Is that true? We'll look at that.
Speaker 2: We won twice and now we've got to win
a third time. They know that we can defeat them.
They know that we will defeat them. But they're
not coming after me. They're coming after you.
Speaker 1: Right. This is a classic, which is
by trying to hold me accountable for crimes
for which there is evidence, you are really
being targeted. It's like, no, no, no. They're
targeting you for the things you allegedly did.
Speaker 2: I'm just standing in
their way. Right. And I always
will stand in their way. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: That video released just after the
stroke of midnight, early this morning. And of
course, as unhinged, panicked and desperate as
ever, all four investigations are merely Democrats
going after Trump because the polls are so great
for Trump. The truth is that the polls are good
for Trump. They're not absolutely fantastic.
And in fact, Trump does worse against Joe Biden
than does Ron DeSantis just for being thorough.
If you look at some recent polls, yes, there
continue to be polls in which Trump is doing
very well in the Republican primary, but
there are also polls that are quite close.
And it really depends on which poll you look at.
These are Republican primary polls, and Trump is
winning depending on the state or whether it's
a general poll anywhere from between two and 28
over Ron DeSantis. But these are not big surges.
These are what the numbers have been. And then
importantly, if you look at the general election,
Biden against DeSantis versus Biden against Trump,
Biden does better against Trump in every one of
these recent polls. So it's not really true that
there is a polling motivation to try to get Trump
out of the way. If you are Democrats and by the
way, Democrats are Justice Department. Biden in
DC, prosecutor D.A. in New York, the Georgia these
are all different groups is the truth. And just
to say these are just all Democrats is is also
not accurate. But the idea that Democrats would
be saying let's charge Trump to get them out of
the way, why DeSantis does better than Trump.
It wouldn't make any sense to try to do that.